>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
I AM WILL CAIN IN FOR TUCKER.
TONIGHT UNFORTUNATELY THE WORLD
CONTINUES TO FLIRT WITH
WORLD WAR III.
THIS MORNING ACCORDING TO THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS SIGHTING OF
SENIOR U.S. INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL IT IS SAID THAT RUSSIAN
MISSILES "CROSSED INTO NATO
MEMBER POLAND, KILLING TWO
PEOPLE."
>> THE PENTAGON SAYS THEY ARE
TRACKING THESE REPORTS, THOUGH
NOT CONFIRMING ANYTHING RIGHT
OUT OF THE GATES.
BEING VERY CLEAR AND SAYING THAT
THE UNITED STATES STANDS BY
ARTICLE FIVE WHICH IS AN ATTACK
ON ONE NATO COUNTRY IS AN ATTACK
ON ALL AND THAT'S THE CONCERN
HERE.
IF THESE WERE RUSSIAN MISSILES,
ALL WE KNOW RIGHT NOW AS THE
YEARS WERE MISSILES OR ROCKETS
THAT LANDED IN THIS FARM THAT IS
ALONG THE BORDER OF POLAND AND
UKRAINE AND POLISH, KILLING TWO.
IF THOSE WERE RUSSIANS, THEN
THAT IS THE CONCERN HERE, THAT
THE UKRAINE WAR COULD
EXTRAPOLATE AND BECOME SOMETHING
BIGGER.
>> Will: EXTRAPOLATED TO
SOMETHING BIGGER.
THAT WOULDN'T BE THE FIRST TIME
THAT A BUTTERFLY FLAPPED ITS
WINGS IN EASTERN EUROPE.
I GIVE YOU THE ASSASSINATION OF
ARCHDUKE FRANZ FERDINAND FOR
WORLD WAR I BUS AND THEN THE
GLOBAL WAR BLEW THROUGH AMERICA
SO THAT'S NOT EXTRAPOLATE INTO A
NUCLEAR CONFLICT THIS TIME
WITHOUT ASKING HARD QUESTIONS
AND ASKING FOR SOBER LEADERSHIP.
YOU HEARD IN THAT REPORT THE
MENTION OF ARTICLE FIVE.
THAT'S A SELF-DEFENSE PROVISION
IN THE NATO CHARTER.
IF INVOKED, IT MEANS WORLD WAR
AGAINST RUSSIA.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
WITHIN MINUTES OF THAT APPARENT
STRIKE IN POLAND, THE GOVERNMENT
OF ESTONIA, A NATO ALLY, MADE IT
CLEAR THAT WORLD WAR MIGHT
RESULT.
"ESTONIA IS READY TO DEFEND
EVERY INCH OF NATO TERRITORY.
"IS AMERICA?
THERE ARE REPORTS AN INCIDENT OF
ARTICLE FIVE, POLAND WILL LOOK
TO INVOKE ARTICLE FOUR AND THAT
WOULD GIVE THEM THE POWER TO ASK
NATO TO COME TOGETHER FOR MORE
SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE.
MORE MONEY PERHAPS, AIR AND
ANTIAIR POWER OVER UKRAINE.
IN FACT THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY
ASKED CONGRESS FOR ANOTHER
$37 MILLION AND OF COURSE
THEY'LL GET THAT FOR UKRAINE.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHOEVER WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MISSILE
STRIKE IN POLAND, THEY'RE ABOUT
TO GET EVEN RICHER.
DEFENSE CONTRACTORS.
LOOK, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED YET IN POLAND.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THOSE
MISSILES CAME FROM.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS THE
INTENDED TARGET.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS A
MISTAKE.
RUSSIA DENIES LAUNCHING THE
ATTACK.
THE PENTAGON HASN'T CONFIRMED IT
EVEN HAPPENED.
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY OF
COURSE HAS BLAMED RUSSIA.
BUT WE SHOULD KNOW THE ANSWERS
TO THESE QUESTIONS BEFORE WE
ZOMBIE WALK INTO WAR.
THESE QUESTIONS CAN'T JUST BE
BRUSHED AWAY WITH PUTIN
APOLOGISTS OR CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, THE SAME WAY THAT WAS
DONE WITH COVID ORIGINS, VACCINE
EFFICACY, LOCKDOWN EFFICACY,
MASK EFFICACY, OR ASKING FOR
DETAILS AND FACTS AROUND THE
ATTACK OF PABLO C.
MORE ON THAT IN A MOMENT.
SADLY IT'S CLEAR THAT OUR
LEADERSHIP IN WASHINGTON IS IN
NO SHAPE TO HANDLE ANY OF THIS.
JOE BIDEN HAD TO SKIP DINNER
WITH THE WORLD LEADERS AT THE
G20 SUMMIT LAST NIGHT IN BALI,
RETREATING BACK TO HIS HOTEL
ROOM FOR UNDISCLOSED REASONS.
HE WAS JUST ON TELEVISION BEFORE
WE BROADCAST LOOKING CONFUSED IN
FRONT OF TELEVISION CAMERAS
TONIGHT.
IT'S PROBABLY ALL BETTER BECAUSE
IF YOU ARE AWAKE OR LUCID, HE
MIGHT VERBALLY STUMBLE US INTO
HIROSHIMA.
WORDS ARE POWER.
SPEAKING OF THE POWER OF WORDS,
LIKE FAMOUS BASKETBALL DAD LAVAR
BALL SPEAKING IT INTO EXISTENCE.
FENTANYL FLOWS ACROSS AND KILLS
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS.
>> I HAVE HEARD YOU AND THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE RECENTLY IN
THE SUMMER AND TESTIFY THAT THE
BORDER IS SECURE.
SECRETARY MAYORKAS, DO YOU
MAINTAIN THAT THE BORDER IS
SECURE?
>> YES, AND WE ARE WORKING DAY
IN AND DAY OUT.
>> UNDEFEATED, NEVER LOST.
MORE THAN 230,000 PEOPLE CROSS
THE BORDER LAST MONTH COMPARED
TO 60,000 IN OCTOBER 2019.
THIS IS WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER COURTESY
OF FOX'S BILL MELUGIN.
>> THIS VIDEO FROM EARLIER.
THIS IS DRONE VIDEO, SHOWING A
SINGLE MASSIVE GROUP OF SEVERAL
HUNDRED MIGRANTS CROSSING
ILLEGALLY INTO NORMANDY TEXAS, A
TINY TOWN ON THE NORTHERN
OUTSKIRTS OF EAGLE PASS AND AS
YOU LOOK AT THIS YOU'LL SEE JUST
A SINGLE FILE LINE OF
MIGRANTS WADING ACROSS THE
RIO GRANDE RIO GRANDE AND
ENTERING TEXAS.
THERE'S NO RESISTANCE ON EITHER
SIDE OF THE BORDER WHATSOEVER
AND ONCE THESE MIGRANTS GET TO
THE U.S. SIDE, THEY SIMPLY CRAWL
UNDER A FENCE THAT WAS PUT UP BY
THE STATE OF TEXAS, AND THEY
WALK INTO AN AREA WHERE THEY
WAIT TO BE PROCESSED BY BORDER
PATROL AND THEY ARE JUST --
A COUPLE HOURS AFTER THAT FORMAL
VIDEO WE HAD ANOTHER GROUP OF
MIGRANTS CROSSING INTO THE
EAGLE PASS AREA AT A PRIVATE
PECAN ORCHARD.
BORDER PATROL SOURCE TELLING
FOX NEWS HERE IN THIS DEL RIO
SECTOR, JUST SINCE OCTOBER 1,
THERE'VE ALREADY BEEN NEARLY
50,000 ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
>> Will: TOTALLY UNIMPEDED.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS --
HOW SHOULD REPUBLICANS RESPOND
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LED
BY JOE BIDEN REFUSES TO ACT?
TODAY IT APPEARS ONE REPUBLICAN
ACTUALLY DID SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
OR DID HE?
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
SEEMED TO DECLARE AN INVASION IS
IN PROGRESS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF TEXAS, THAT MOVE
WOULD AUTHORIZE TEXAS TO
INDEPENDENTLY CRUSH THE SURGE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITHOUT
NEEDING ANY APPROVAL FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SPECIFICALLY GREG ABBOTT'S
DECISION TO INVOKE THE INVASION
CLASS WOULD ALLOW TEXAS TO
DEPLOY THE NATIONAL GUARD AND
TEXAS DPS TO REMOVE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
BUT IN HIS PRESS RELEASE TODAY
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT SAID
HE WOULD REMOVE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO THE BORDER.
WAIT.
TO THE BORDER.
KEN CUCCINELLI, FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF VIRGINIA AT
A BIG LEADER IN THE PUSH FOR
STATES TO DECLARE INNOVATION
POINTS OUT TO THE BORDER IS NOT
DEPORTATION.
IT WOULDN'T STEM THE TIDE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
AND IT DOESN'T INVOKE THE FULL
CONSTITUTIONAL POWER OF
DECLARING AN INVASION.
SO IS NOT JUST A PRESS RELEASE?
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WORDS?
OR IS THIS POTENTIALLY
LEADERSHIP?
REPUBLICANS NOW HAVE THE HOUSE.
AT ANY MOMENT TONIGHT IT COULD
BE CALLED THE REPUBLICANS NOW
HAVE A MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE AND
THEN THE QUESTION BECOMES MIGHT
THEY BE ABLE TO LEAD IN ACTUALLY
SOLVING THE BORDER CRISIS OR MAY
BE RETURNING OUR ELECTIONS TO
PRE-PANDEMIC ELECTION LAWS OR
MAYBE EVEN BEING THE SORELY
LACKING SOBER LEADERSHIP WE NEED
BEFORE WE EXTRAPOLATE OURSELVES
INTO WORLD WAR III.
FOR TOO LONG NOW, WE'VE BEEN
GASLIGHT, SHOUTED DOWN,
CENSORED, OUR QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN CALLED CONSPIRACIES.
WHILE THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE IS
TORTURED TO THE POINT WHERE YOU
CAN NO LONGER EXPLAIN WHAT IS A
WOMAN OR HER WHY WE ARE GOING TO
WAR.
WE NEED LEADERS, HONEST LEADERS
OF ANY PARTY AT ANY LEVEL